[Musique]
local pour célébrer l'annexion des
quatre jours ukrainiennes au-delà du
coût de force et des condamnations
internationales que cela représente
est-ce qu'il y a un intérêt économique à
faire tout ça à stratégie alors
forcément quand on procède un tel
mouvement il y a toujours un intérêt
économique derrière on parle là de
quatre régions qui représentent 20%
environ du territoire ukrainien et qui
sont en partie en grande partie
russophone le premier intérêt pour la
Russie c'est de créer une continuité
territoriale
avec la Crimée entre la Russie
finalement et la Crimée je cherche
j'attendais la carte on la voit ici
cette Crimée et là on voit la continuité
territoriale que cela pourrait
représenter avec tous les avantages que
cela pourrait également représenter
évidemment en temps de paix pour la
Russie notamment aussi pour les
transports avec des accès à la mer pour
passer de la mer en particulier des
ports de Mario Paul qu'on trouve ici
dans la région de nietzk et de bédiante
dans la région de zappoza ou bien cet
accès à la mer Noire ici dans la région
de Kerson pour ça pour transporter les
marchandises vers Moscou ou bien vers
Saint-Pétersbourg et puis c'est 4
régions ont chacune aussi un intérêt
économique les deux républiques du
dombasque qu'on voit ici loin et Donetsk
ce sont le bassin minier de l'Ukraine
avec de nombreuses mines de charbon de
des usines de sidérurgies de métallurgie
les deux régions représentaient donner
c'est la plus riche des quatrains et de
et ces deux régions représentaient avant
2010 environ 17% du PIB
ukrainien je dis avant 2010 parce que
c'était avant le conflit avec les
séparatistes prorus celles de zapporitza
qu'on voit ici que pourrait être
qualifié de cœur
nucléaire du pays avec cette grande
centrale du nom de zaporizza qui se
trouve en réalité dans une autre ville
dans la ville
Denner rodar qui avait été débranché il
y a quelques semaines avant d'être
partiellement partiellement reconnecté
au réseau cette région est représente 4%
du PIB du l'Ukraine avant la guerre
enfin la région de Kerson qu'on voit ici
la plus
occidentale c'est le cœur qu'on pourrait
qualifier de grenier à blé de l'Ukraine
et donc du monde mais c'est important
stratégique et économique qu'il faut la
relativiser avec le risque prend
Vladimir Poutine avec ses élections oui
car la Russie s'expose évidemment à de
nouvelles sanctions américaines d'abord
Washington prévoit d'annoncer de
nouvelles sanctions contre des
personnalités russes dans les prochaines
heures et surtout aussi européenne
puisque les 27 vont décréter un huitième
train de sanctions aujourd'hui qui
prévoit notamment un plafonnement du
prix du pétrole russe livré vers des
pays tiers l'interdiction également
d'exporter vers l'Europe des diamants
russes ou encore surtout d'importer vers
la réussite des composants électroniques
européens des personnalités européennes
n'auront plus le droit de siéger dans
des entreprises russes tout cela
s'ajoutent évidemment à une longue liste
de sanctions je disais 8 trains qui
visent déjà les secteurs financiers des
transports de l'énergie russe mais aussi
de nombreuses personnalités russes et
c'est la question que tout le monde se
pose est-ce que ces sanctions sont
efficaces est-ce qu'elles touchent
réellement l'économie russe alors on
entend parfois certains dire que ce ne
serait pas efficace reprenant parfois
comme argument un rapport du FMI début
juillet qui disait que le pays la Russie
résistait plutôt bien et en voulait pour
preuve le rouble qu'on voit la monnaie
russe qui après avoir effectivement
chuté au début de la guerre face à
l'euro c'est largement repris et
largement même maintenant au dessus de
l'euro mais faut dire que cette monnaie
russe elle a été artificiellement
soutenu par la Banque centrale à Moscou
et qu'en réalité ces sanctions elles
font mal elles font même très mal à la
Russie un rapport confidentiel risque
Blumberg c'est procurer il y a quelques
semaines laisse même penser que la
situation serait catastrophique pour la
Russie le rapport fait plusieurs
scénarios et dans le meilleur des cas
l'économie russe se contracte très
l'année prochaine on le voit ici en vert
de
-3,3 8% après avoir déjà baissé de 3%
cette année ce serait moins 1,3% 2024
mais dans le pire des scénarios et de
pire des scénarios les la Russie et la
l'économie russe s'effondrerait de 11%
et près de 12% en 2024 ce qui est énorme
la raison c'est que la situation
actuelle a provoqué une fuite des
cerveaux notamment des spécialistes en
informatique qui s'accélèrent d'ailleurs
avec les derniers appels à la
mobilisation de réserviste on voit on va
on peut voir on voit souvent ces images
et là on les voit ici en Géorgie film
peu près trois jours de russe qui quitte
leur pays et et donc le pays est
également privé de composants
électroniques et d'autres produits qui
sont visés aujourd'hui par des sanctions
ce qui est handicap la production russe
enfin les coupures de gaz destiné
alors notamment l'embargo également sur
le pétrole prive le pays d'importants
revenus et même si Moscou a trouvé
d'autres débouchés d'autres marchés en
Chine et en Inde notamment et il profite
c'est vrai aussi de la hausse des prix
de l'énergie tout cela ne suffit pas à
compenser le manque à gagner merci
beaucoup pour toutes ces explications
c'était l'info